I have a million questions for you okay
I like throwing things off
um at the beginning with you know I have
a lot of questions anyway let's just get
started
um you stopped by our Sundance studio in
2020 for farewell
um and um and at the time I think you
would shot the Batman and it had or
maybe you hadn't shot I don't know but
what has the last few years been like
for you because at that moment you had
done a tiny little bit and now you've
worked with all these different people
what what has this last few years been
like it's been crazy dude I can't I I
and it's gone by so fast you know like
as much information as I feel like I'm
having to
um uh uh soak up uh with all these
different uh platforms and people and
artists that I'm getting to work with
but it's been it's been it's been great
I can't I is unreal unreal yeah I can't
imagine what it's like for you
um but you've worked with such great
actors and all these talented directors
and I'm curious what have you learned in
the last few years that he didn't teach
you in like acting school
you know what's interesting actually I
don't know that it's about that I
necessarily learned anything different
but trying to translate what I learned
into these other mediums that's more so
what the learning curve has been
um uh like because all the work is the
same like the work that I I grew up
training um for theater it's the same
kind of work it's just trying to
translate it
um into a different kind of schedule or
or way or process
um
and I was so lucky to start with
farewell and more to have that you know
it's like my kind of like transition
period to you know a small indie project
to to figure a lot of things out and ask
a bunch of questions and not feel a
whole lot of pressure
um so it's been good just to test
everything out test everything out with
different directors and different roles
and different actors and have the
privilege of like watching Masters up
close at work
yeah yeah it's great no I mean there's a
lot of people
um it's uh uh it's like having it like
you're essentially Apprentice like
you're taking an apprenticeship and
you're watching like Viola Davis work
next to you you're like oh this is how
she does it this is how I need to do it
it's like it's like the special days of
it's like I get to have a master class
every day I show up to set that's how it
feels to me I'm like okay I get to watch
these Masters at work and I'm stealing
this and I'm soaking this up and I'm I'm
remembering this moment and how you do
this right like just gotta be a thief on
set
completely um so I love learning about
how actors like to prepare obviously
you've only been doing you've only been
working in the industry if you will for
a little while but have you noticed that
the way you prepare for each role is
similar or have you adjusted it slightly
based on your experiences
um it's definitely similar I mean it it
depends on the role right like any I've
had the I have the privilege of getting
to work on
um historical women uh and so
that takes a ton of research for me like
that's probably where I start
immediately is just in digging in
I want to know every kind of backstory
detail I could possibly know about your
childhood uh uh uh uh and and building
that that Arc
um I like listening to different
interviews
um figuring out like the kind of music
that they listen to you know
um but I I have a similar approach even
the fictional characters just trying to
create you know that kind of backstory
and create a full full character even
down to the tiny little details um
if I can if I have enough time to do
that I
I try to luxuriate in that it's so funny
there's so many people that don't really
realize the way the business Works in
terms of I've spoken to actors that that
tell me they got the role two days
before filming yet and it's just you're
just doing the best you can you just
trying to wing it
just trying to do the best you possibly
can yeah uh so jumping into till
um it is uh I saw it last night uh okay
yeah very powerful film
um I'm so happy it was made and I wanted
to sort of touch on that the fact that
like it's hard to believe that this film
and the story takes place less than 70
years ago it's still so recent and it
it's just so infuriating to me
um can you sort of talk about that
aspect this is our recent history and
it's shameful
yeah I I
um like you said it's very recent and
and somehow I think the shocking thing
for me especially during everything that
was happening with George Floyd
um it kind of resurrected in a way as if
most as this bit had been forgotten or
wasn't even known to a lot of people
um
which was different for me because I
grew up with knowing the horror of what
happened with Emmett Till and
and like you said it is it is it is
still very much it's history but it's
still very much a part of what's
happening in the present day I mean the
fact that that uh the lynching bill has
just get got passed
ah it we can't chalk this up to
something that happened uh a while ago
when uh change is just starting to
happen as a result of it now in 2022.
um so
yeah I'm I'm so thankful that you know
you took this on to to tell this story
and to honor Mamie in particular because
often when we talk about Emmett
um we talk about the horror that was
done to him but we don't
um we don't talk about his mother and
the kind of bravery and courage that it
took in the midst of her grief uh to
share her son with the world
um so I I'm really excited for this film
I'm really excited for it oh and also um
you know and I want to make sure
Danielle right she uh that yeah yeah so
Danielle her performance is riveting
um and it's so
you know um and what is it like because
you have a we have one key scene with
her and and I don't know if you shop
more than that if anything was deleted
but there's one key scene in the movie
and I'm just curious what it was like
sharing the screen with her watching her
deliver such a great performance you
know in all these scenes it's a gift oh
my God as an actress you you hope to
have a moment like that that scene is
the only no nothing was cut what's in
that um in the film is what was on the
page
um and
um getting to I mean Danielle is uh who
she's a force and getting that
opportunity to just show up because I
was only there for like two days of
filming into and they would already been
in the process you know so I I'm trying
to figure out how to step in and fit in
into the world that's already been
created
um but even before then her and I got on
the zoo we had like meetings just
talking about the scene and breaking it
down and what does this mean for these
two women to come together and talking
with Chino and oh I I cherish that
moment because you live for moments like
that
um and to be opposite and actress that
that that giving that generous
um and and willing to really build
something in that moment
um yeah she's she's absolutely
phenomenal in this role uh I couldn't
agree more
um I mean she's fantastic
um but the thing that I didn't realize
was how involved Medgar Edgars was in
Emmett's story I didn't I didn't I
didn't know this stuff um and I knew I
know Med Greg anyway but can you sort of
talk about the responsibility of playing
a real person Medgar Edgar's wife and
the fact that you mentioned like you
have very limited time on screen to make
the audience understand
what also she's going through and the
sacrifices that she's making right well
when we talked about
um when I talked with Chennai about
merly Evers
um
and particularly at this pivotal moment
um
what happened with Emmett was a turning
point um for a lot of people in the
country right because it was the first
time really that something we uh anybody
saw that kind of brutality publicized
you know
um it was always it was maybe talked
about in hush but nobody had ever really
seen it
um and
from early
um she was young she was 22.
she's 22 when Emmett was murdered and
she had just had a son
and so for me and approaching early I
felt like this was a key moment of of a
decision having to be made uh
of really understanding the kind of
sacrifice that she was gonna have to
make if she was to continue to support
Medgar in his efforts and and realizing
that she was having to give Medgar up to
the cause
um and there was a different weight to
it now because she's a mother she's a
young mother
and
and what she's going to have to
sacrifice in order to continue to show
up
um and she was younger than I am in
making these decisions like that's what
blew me away because often we talk about
these um Heroes of history and they feel
so distant because they feel like they
were older when they were when they were
showing up for these causes and like no
they were in their 20s their early 20s
um to make that kind of sacrifice and
she definitely learned something from
Mamie
um and how Mamie showed up it gave
backbone I think yeah I can't imagine
being 22 and making you know I don't
know yeah it's just but um the thing
that's crazy is you shared the screen
with Danielle and you shared the screen
with Viola and these are two of the best
performances I've seen you know these
are these are fantastic performances
this year do you sort of feel like you
should be playing the lottery you know
like in terms of like you know like how
lucky you are to be working with these
and and watching these you know what I
mean yeah I I you know what is part luck
but it's also
um
I feel like
you give out a certain energy it's bound
to be reciprocated you know what I mean
and like I feel like I I just
I give out such intentionality and uh
respect and honor for the craft and the
kind of roles that I I care about and so
I feel really blessed that it's being
reciprocated especially so early on like
because I know that that that's rare but
I'm gonna ride that for as long as I can
no completely I listen I have a lot of
actor friends and
um it's really really hard yeah it's
just really hard so I I say but listen
you I say congrats but were you with
with woman king
um you you're one of the people that
didn't have to do some of the crazy
fight stuff and stunts yeah were you
sort of like when you saw were you happy
that you didn't have to do those stunt
scenes and those big action set pieces
or were there days where you're like man
I'd like to be doing that training and
doing that stuff I'll say this I um I'm
the first when I first showed up um they
were filming
um
the the the uh Warrior dance
um uh sequence right before they go out
to battle
and I'm sitting there and I'm like
chills like chills up my arm and my
tears rubbing up in my eyes and I see
Gina and I'm just like
can the queen just like come out there
and do a little
hear them do the a Goji wuzu the warrior
cry and I was like oh can there be a
moment where I can just you know just a
little something
um it was definitely inspiring to see uh
uh I did not envy them on the days where
we were in the brutal sun and and and
I'm under a nice little canopy uh I
didn't envy that but uh it definitely
made me hungry for for something like
that that kind of regring chaining and
you know because I'm a physical actor
anyway
um but I I commend them for that because
that that took a lot out of them yeah I
spoke to John and uh I asked him what it
was like you know not having to do the
physical stuff yeah and he he shared a
story about going to biola's house and
he asked where the juice is and
everyone's like no it's water you know
what it was just a whole thing uh it was
just funny to you know to hear about
that but talk if you don't mind talk a
little bit about getting to be part of
that project as well because obviously
it's like an A plus with Cinema score
people love it it turned out so great
um can you sort of talk about what it
means to you
um I knew I had to be a part of that
project and I didn't care what I didn't
care what it was I remember telling Gina
that I was like I just got to be a part
of this because it's history and
I know
people might not have known how it was
gonna do but everybody that was a part
of the project had a complete faith in
it
um and knew that it was important uh
and we've never seen it before like
we've never seen a global box office
movie led by nothing but black women
like that has never existed and the fact
that that's never existed is also like
mind-boggling
um
and like it's a it's just a it's an
amazing film like what are we talking
about like it's just like a really great
film full of talented actors
um
I that uh yeah I I'm really happy and
like proud that I got to be a part of
that and any chance I get to tell Viola
and Gina I'm like y'all did this y'all
did it like
like you thank you you made this space
you made it happen thank you also um
people don't realize getting an A plus
Cinema score is not easy it is a very
very like a is it happens a plus is like
very rare and I also like it my cat
decides to interrupt our interviews and
just you know uh just showing because it
gives no [ __ ] at the same time that's
all yeah you know um so I definitely
want to ask you though um because
obviously
owned of the year is the Batman I think
that you know Matt Reeves just did such
an amazing job
um can you sort of talk a little bit
about getting to be a part of that
project and was it weird not being able
to like tell anyone anything about the
movie for so long
um I had fun with that actually I had
fun being secretive I I don't know
there's something I'm like that anyway
um like I'm really good at planning
surprises for people so I like not being
able like when people ask me ah you know
you just gotta wait to see it Adam I
can't no and people like can't like I
had a family constantly trying to ask me
questions in different ways I'm like
guys I'm not saying anything uh
but yeah I that
had so much fun working on that that was
like right after farewell more so talk
about jumping in the deep end you know
um but everybody a part of that project
too was just like a like Matt
dream director
um and Dylan the um one of the producers
just they were all amazing and so warm
and welcoming to me they didn't make me
feel uh out of place
as a as a kind of newcomer
um so yeah I absolutely love them what
was can you watch yourself on screen
what was it like actually watching
Batman for the first time because you
you are obviously in a section of the
movie so you don't really I'm not sure
how much you knew about what was going
to happen and also with with uh Jay
Kino's music and I mean it's it's just
such a anyway I'm just curious what it
was like for you and if you can watch
yourself on screen
uh I could definitely watch myself in
that because it ain't about me so like I
could just enjoy it as a fan you know
what I mean like I didn't have to I
didn't have to be you see me pop in and
out but I didn't have to be concerned
about that I could really enjoy the film
um I'm getting better about learning how
to
watch myself I remember the first time I
saw myself which was with farewell more
and I like cringed because I'm not used
to that I was never like I don't think
we're meant to see ourselves I just
don't feel like that
um but also my brain I think is is is
calculating and working in other
capacities outside of acting so I'm
trying to get myself you know uh
to to be able to to to to enjoy and
watch a film uh without cringing at
myself coming up on the screen I'm not
succeeding all the way but I'm I'm
definitely getting better
definitely getting better I was gonna
say to you there's a ton of actors I
know who uh when they're at the world
premiere of a movie uh they wave at
everyone they say hi and they walk right
up and yeah they will not watch it
because they just they can't do it I
think that'll be different it may be
different if I'm like leading a film I
feel like then there might be something
where it's like oh I don't know that I
want to sit through this
um but I get the pleasure of actually
enjoying the films that I'm I'm I I'm
I'm a part of right now you know what I
mean so completely did it end up did the
film end up turning out better than you
expected
um or was with the Batman
or did you know going in like this is
going to be amazing I knew going because
I
read the script change anything from
the script literally what's on the
what's it was on the screen was what we
read
um so when I first read that script I
was like
oh no this is about to be epic
right
yeah like Epic
um and then to see it fully with all the
elements again as a fan I just was
living I was living for it last last
question on this
um one of the things that people don't
realize is when you're in a huge film
like the Batman that gets you know makes
all this money and everyone watches it
it's like getting in front of every
casting agent
um all at once because everyone's
watching the movie and so everyone is
you know they're they're seeing you for
probably the first time did you find
after the movie came out obviously
you've booked a number of things but did
you find afterwards that all of a sudden
you were taking more meetings meeting
more people do you know what I mean
this is interesting you know why because
of the pandemic
when that when Batman came out by the
time Batman came out
um
it was more so the fact that people knew
that I gotten cast in it that peaked a
lot of casting directors interest
because it's like who is this girl that
just got out of college and she's in the
Batman what so the word of mouth
definitely got me a whole lot of
meetings and then once that came out and
then first lady came out uh
it was like okay we're seeing and now
I've had like a lot of projects that
I've been a part of come out this year
it's like oh who is she wait a second
you know
um
but the the word of mouth definitely got
me very far before anybody saw any of it
um so yeah yeah I was gonna make a joke
that you should send Matt a thank you
card for the casting you know like oh I
tell them all the time I'm like I'm one
of the I tell people what I'm so
grateful like I was like Matt yeah y'all
didn't have to do this y'all really
didn't have to ask me
no I mean uh yeah I'm I'm messing around
but so I just read that you got cast in
genius MLK X I'm not sure uh so when I
mean that's another talk about these
like history history yeah so is this
like gonna be the mo from now on is I'm
just taking historical parts or is it
just
no
um but I I'm just so honored that I can
do this I think because
it speaks again to
for me it's always been about it's
always about
um
showing a kind of agency or for with
black women especially in this industry
that that seems to be a new phenomena
but it's always existed so the fact that
I'm getting to tell these stories of of
women from our history and bring them to
the Forefront
um I'll take those on any day but no
that's not gonna I'm not gonna just be
doing historical pieces listen I'm just
messing around I think the fact that
you're being asked to play these
important women is honestly it's a
privilege and it's it's amazing and the
you know that it's please I I mean it's
um but so when do you actually have you
started filming when are you filming it
no we uh I actually leave for Atlanta in
like a week so
um yeah I'm in I'm in research mode
right now I'm head deep deep deep in uh
in prep in my in my Hubble with all my
books um uh which is like my happy place
right now so I'm excited I'm really
excited uh and you also mentioned
obviously you got to play Michelle Obama
um is is it one of those things where
you secretly hope she's gonna see it
no
no that's too much pressure for me I
don't I wouldn't no
if no If Ever I get to meet her I just I
really don't want her to say anything
about seeing me portray her I really
don't that's
uh
so you've obviously played or an about
to play a lot of historical important
women is or all of them for you the same
pressure that you put on yourself
because each person is so important or
did you find or have you found that one
really got where you're like a lot
putting more pressure on yourself for
one of these
that's a good question I don't know
I don't know
um I think they all present their own
kind of pressure right like with playing
um a younger version of Michelle Obama
um that's my hero you know what I mean
um and
yeah I just uh that's part of why I
didn't want to talk to her because I was
like if I talk to you I don't know that
I can fully show up
as you you know what I mean like I don't
know that I can can really do that
um I got to talk to merley Evers though
um in prepping for
for
um till and
that was a huge benefit
um right I think also because it's just
it was just a primarily one little scene
in the movie so
there wasn't like a whole pressure of
having to like tell her entire life
story
um and then with prepping for Betty
again it's a it's just a different it's
different kinds of pressure
um but I just feel the need to tell the
truth and honor them as as best as I
possibly can and honor them in their
complexity as best as I can
yeah completely on that note I'm just
going to say I really appreciate your
time I wish you nothing but the best